satire is undoubtedly one of the
most important philosophers of the
twentieth century. his existence
influenced not
only the academic discussion, but
the entire western civilization,
especially the european youth. in
france, after the second world war,
there was
even a youth culture of its own up until the 1960s: pupils,
students, artists  and intellectuals
wore
black clothes and warm glasses as
they used to wear as a sign of their existentialist attitude and the
motto of the existentialists was
don't let anyone tell you how you live
hate-love sincerely and intensely
both in terms of his love
relationships and friendships as well as
his  political commitments sattel
was the great philosopher of
freedom no one
else emphasized human freedom of will so much and
because people are free they have to
make something out of their lives and live it
as they want to
if necessary, he also goes against social
rules and traditions said,
for example, was a committed
opponent of the war fought for a more just
society wrote hundreds of petitions
and
had a so-called open relationship with his partner simone wo was a so-called open
relationship at
the time that was still a scandal in
his main work be and nothing
he  founded saw also appears as one of
the first philosophers the nature of
love
how does love really work what
differentiates it from sexuality what
does it mean to lead a free and
self-determined life
how free we are i tried in
the book full 60 minutes his
most important theses text  his
thoughts on freedom and the structure of
interpersonal relationships are the
focus of his thoughts on freedom and
the structure of
interpersonal relationships in the
chapter what is useful and saddle
today
society shown